didja to do the dodo did you do do do do
that's right guy for our viewing Star
Trek me off right this [ __ ] with you
boldly go where I am your finer that was
a lost in space theme song yeah no good
I'm Gregory John Knowles JJ Abrams and
not return to direct the sequel j-stars
victory and said they got the director
who helmed fast and the furious four
through six Justin Lin Justin who I
sometimes get confused for James one cuz
they're both Asian happens this film is
getting wonderful feedback I've been
trying to go watch it a second time
because I feel like something is wrong
with okay because something is like what
I don't I didn't enjoy this film that
much it's been a few years since into
darkness I did that thing that normally
works against me where I binge-watching
like her Oh at Star Trek star trek into
darkness on that I go to the theaters
and it's not good doing that I noticed
especially when it's been a few years a
movie franchise that's that's big but
it's not like you know comic book status
huge these days you know yeah the star
trek movie franchise specifically my big
pilot's got its dedicated fans and
millions of followers I really doubt
that these films are gonna cross like a
billion dollars I like I don't think
they're gonna make the same amount of
money that like a marble film would make
or Star Wars film would make for the
most part their machine is so I feel
like that with their Star Trek films
specifically this one I felt like they
treated it as if the audience hasn't
seen Star Trek in a while so we need to
make sure we tell it in a way that's
different I got that vibe especially oh
you're not to argue we've done this
twice over let's do it in a way that's
different you know oh there we go the
were different I really like the Star
Trek one that JJ the both Star Trek
films with JJ Abrams did I really loved
the first one and I really like the
second one not as much as the first one
but I really do like it this one though
it's like the things that I thought made
it cool and what a lot of people really
loved about it were the things that
actually kind of bothered me about the
film for one I didn't watch this in 3d
this is like a technical thing not a
storytelling thing but it does bother me
a lot that when I go to watch a film and
it's not in 3d is that the special
effects look like utter [ __ ] because
it's so obviously like tending to 3d I
went with a group of people and we saw
in a 2d format and there were so many
times rubes
each other like what is up with these
special effects and then I figured out
that everyone else i know that watched
it started 3d or bothered at all by the
effects but i thought a lot of them were
really bad except the Star Trek and rise
car crashing constantly that enterprise
ship does not know how to stay me and
Chris Pine I'm like the motorcycle and
[ __ ] I don't think that was it okay this
movie to me felt like it totally lie and
character what oh wow how do you mean
that them this film I know is a love
letter to the Star Trek original show
that's the biggest thing about it it's
like the 50th I was at the 50th
celebration 75th some celebration sorry
right so I know it's doing a huge homage
to the original show the show was a
low-budget show and it did rely a lot
more on situations not so much on like
crazy Hollywood action like the reboots
are able to incorporate now well they
were doing sci-fi because it was a
chance to discuss things that you
couldn't just discuss with human
character sure if you watch the one that
JJ Abrams did and I think if you set up
this reboot series like that where Kirk
like the first five minutes of starting
that Star Trek movie with Chris
Hemsworth's roll people [ __ ] baller
eyes out and then the whole journey of
Chris Pine having to accept this destiny
in him and then having to embrace his
leadership silac he has to go from a
loader to becoming a leader and Spock is
his person who struggles with embracing
his emotions and knowing when to act on
emotions there's a lot of emotional
layers in there into darkness has a law
that would Benedict Cumberbatch this one
though was just a was just another
episode of Star Trek to me it was just
another plot I'm gonna go out on a limb
here and say this is the first of them
where I really felt like Chris Pine was
a leader first of his Kirk's I felt like
yeah this guy's just a leader like I'm
not watching cuz the thing is like I
like the first star trick to I should
rewatch it cuz it's least fresh in my
mind have you seen the first instra two
or three and I remember into darkness
more but the thing is like the first
Star Trek it's like you said he's like
he's finding his destiny and learning
how to lead and he's still very much
like a brash like I do my own thing guy
and it's like I've seen that story more
times in this one he did feel like the
leader of a crew
not a guy who had a bunch of people
following they really handled the crew
well in this movie like I really got
this sense best out of all of them that
this is a crew who's all like every
member is important everybody pulls
their weight and everyone is integral to
the adventure that's an episode of Star
Trek totally as a movie though that has
set itself up with a very specific tone
I feel like if you're gonna reboot Star
Trek I don't think you should just go
back and divert to making it just
another episode of the series I'm the
long run of things I don't feel like any
of this really has a major effect on any
of the characters in terms of their
growth but here's the thing like and
this is this is more of a philosophical
film too baby cuz now franchises have
changed it used to be like oh we got a
sequel and now it's a whole other story
franchises are expected to just go on
now so they are like giant TV shows in a
certain point you can't always convince
us that this might be the end for our
heroes every single time I get what
you're saying first it doesn't really do
that I guess the person second would
definitely don't do that I mean despite
the whole thing with like Kurt died like
10 minutes in the second ones they made
him go into the reactor core and they're
like you know you might die and Spock
finally screams not it's not about that
though it's it's about the emotional
effect that the these journeys have on
these characters seriously man I really
feel like I can go back and watch the
worse the month I feel like if you watch
the first Star Trek i binge watch this
with a couple of other people to eric is
lungs like and what and that was with
the whole opening monologue I don't
think and I be seals too she stays in
Albany dresses to say that he's like the
leader when most of the movie they're
all split up he's not leading them for
most of the film era but he feels like a
leader and he behaves like a leader and
in the scenes where they are all
together I bought him most as a legit
Starfleet leader not as you know like
rebellious Captain Kirk he seemed like
leader cast anchor ok but this journey
to me jizz just another episode in their
adventure this is like this could have
been a like 20 minute retelling if they
wanted two of them telling the story at
a camp on it's another adventure it's
another adventure but it is not about
this there's no there's no emotional
investment in this story for me at all
and I really feel like that's the big
disappointment for me because it is just
about the plot at hand it's only about
that Enterprise gets destroyed again
they crash like they're all separate for
most of the movie and while you get some
great scenes it's a rather small film
really small that made it feel like more
like a real adventure in a way cuz it's
you see every movie like this now is all
about how big we can be and this one is
like it is kind of small and that's a
cool change of pace I mean like I one
place a lot of the time when I say small
I also mean that it lacks tension it
lacks dispense it lacks like worry a lot
of interest I felt like it dragged a lot
of time the stakes I didn't know try
some I mean I like the stuff with bones
and Spock were great i love that [ __ ]
yeah but and that was like Scotty and
jayla to I thought she was terrific
that's thought she did a great job she
does do a great and she's a lot of
makeup to act through and she could have
gone through and not been anything
special but she stood out to me every
time she that's great but by the time
they also get to Idris Elba's like
explanation as to who he is like we're
like almost done with the film now I
don't really give a [ __ ] I didn't really
care about Idris Elba's performance or
his role the final conclusion with his
character showdown between him and
Couric was just like it just felt it but
very empty and emotions to me especially
after the heavyset onslaught of emotions
that the first and second one give us
okay and even with this one with Spock
they set up early on that original Spock
is dead and I thought that was like a
cool set up to play on Spock's emotions
like holy [ __ ] I could actually die you
know didn't seem to have no real effect
on him throughout the rest of the phone
he's contemplating leaving so that he
can go basically helped populate Vulcan
that's a plot point it doesn't mean it's
felt and it doesn't really that it's
like really there it's just a plot point
where they throw in information you shut
up John here not let me talk I'm keep
talking on I'll give you this because
the movie does move so immediately and
because there are so many characters who
are all split on I wasn't the most
emotionally invested in this one out of
the other ones the other ones probably
are more thrilling the scene where they
destroy the enterprise is super cool and
Justin Lin
a job directing and i think and i was
really bored during it and I was you
know starting to get heavy eyelids me
that's so weird because I really like
that I really liked it too i don't know
why the action bits were the least sort
of thrilling to me I liked the character
stuff I enjoyed it I get what you're
saying that because we're jumping around
a lot and because people are paired off
the dynamics are different and I get
that it's not big character development
constantly but I thought the different
things they decided to play on and the
themes they decided to bring into that
we're interesting every Star Trek fan
review or professional review professing
to be a Star Trek fan of sorta told me
that this movie kind of splits the
difference and brings in the trek ideas
but doesn't skimp on the Hollywood you
know shininess and I can see that for as
long as blockbusters get now I almost
feel like this one could have been
longer because then we would have gotten
a little more time to really dig in to
all the things these characters are
going through but i think the choices
they made are all good i think that what
they did with them is still good i agree
it could have been more like I could
have been more psyched about it I left
feeling good will but not like I gotta
watch it again I think I think it's a
good plot it's a good adventure but I
felt like there was a lot of substance
that was just really missing for me and
honestly I don't really think it was
missing from the script I really feel
like it was probably in the hands of
Justin Lin has taken over the direction
for this he's not known for being that
great at handling this ingredients that
I actually wanted in this film I'm gonna
steal a point from birth movies death
though because I read the review and
this stood out to me is justin lennox
fast and furious family like he knows
how to handle an ensemble in two and two
at least you know let those characters
be together like what he did with the
fast and the furious but his ensemble
work was getting know what he did with
the Fast and the Furious franchise is
what he did here which is he made it a
really fun movie with this family that's
it yeah that's it but that that's all it
is the fact that it like looked and felt
like the show a lot of the time was cool
in a lot of ways but in a lot of ways it
was kind of like I should just watch an
episode of the show if you're gonna
reboot there's no point in you rebooting
this but it's not your rock show I mean
it's it's still got ingredients that the
new movies brought in still in their
timeline I know this is different from
any idea and I and I've seen at least
one of the old Star Trek movies I'm like
this is different but it does feel like
they made an effort
bring in more of what makes Star Trek
what it is and I appreciated that stuff
about the movie because like seeing the
first two I was like I always get the
complaint that it's a lot more like Star
Wars than it is like Star Trek and I
thought that the stuff they brought in
this time showed a concerted effort to
make their tone a little more distinct
you know maybe our style a little more
distinct it's more fun in the sense of
like just a fun summer movie than the
other two cuz that is your rather dark
and kind of heavy well I the crazy like
ridiculous danger in you know set pieces
are still really big and you're like
those are a lot bigger than we would
have done before probably yeah I mean
there's still stuff here that's
rewarding but here the fourth one
they're gonna bring back Chris Hemsworth
which is gonna be interesting because
Kurt's dad's gonna be really buff yeah
lets you just trust but really I imagine
that's gonna have an emotional effect on
kirkham is probably gonna change the
emotional dynamics a lot of the story
well this third chapter feel as
necessary other than seeing the
inclusion of this new character jayla
jayla it's felt like a Star Trek fan
fiction film team ya know this
definitely felt like we're really trying
to you know think of the Star Trek fans
not being a big you know Star Trek
expert myself like I can still get that
sense you know you really want to show
that this franchise does love Star Trek
this is the better side of fan
interaction to me where I feel like they
really listen and they went we've got a
guy who clearly seems to know Trek on
staff let's just let him write one yes
sure I think this film was meant more
for the trekkie hardcore fans I haven't
seen a lot of the shows but I've seen
like pretty much most of the movies like
even the ones prior to Abraham's version
I'm going off of the in terms of Star
Trek star trek into darkness and now
Star Trek beyond not the whole legacy of
surgery glass I'm going to mention the
big controversial things surrounding
this was the fact that Sulu will be
confirmed in this movie that he's gay I
like oh really do like a lot how they
handle that he's like last like a few
seconds and it's not like like something
kids gay joke it's like you see soon
meet up with this husband and child and
that's it that like its brief and it
just shows you oh he's getting okay cool
yeah it's not like we need to make a big
deal now you know and it's just like
yeah it's like it's cool that's mixed in
with it's just Kirk looking on his crew
I like that this movie did that in a way
we're being gay wasn't like a thing that
they were gonna focus on like it's a big
deal it's like we're two day and age now
where we can treat it like it's not a
big deal I heard side effects reasoning
for that choice and I I like what what
they're going for it don't make a big
deal out of it but it is like a
highlighted moment it is like the focus
of a moment but I thought it's a good
you know it's it's a benevolent it was
like five seconds and you don't see
anyone else is like it doesn't do it
like they're finding out suit who's gay
or some yes I didn't need to do that but
it does it's and it does serve that
scene you know they handled it in a nice
way like they handle it the way you you
shoot and that makes it a broader world
and more encompassing world a more
progressive world sort of Gene
Roddenberry design I give this movie two
out of five warp speeds that's four and
a half eight three and a half I don't
know how much higher than mine it looks
like pretty good right that's pretty
good did pretty good it's like I said
I'm not like championed by wrong guys I
know I have to watch a good time I feel
like I missed the point of this film I'd
like to go with you barely we could do
it a lot of cats to play everyone likes
it with me anyway if you guys are Gaga
about this channel subscribe Gaga bow
John facebooked Jerry bloom house and I
follow Facebook Instagram Twitter social
network sites and we have profiles on
there goodbye but